One of the first times an American was ever brought over to Japan
to lead a professional Japanese baseball team,
Bobby Valentine, in 1995,
he took this really mediocre squad,
he lead them to a stunning second-place finish,
and he was instantly fired.
Why?
"Well," said the team spokesman,
"because of his emphasis on winning."
(Laughter)
Official Japan can feel quite a lot like that point
that was said to last two hours and 12 minutes,
and playing not to lose
can take all the imagination, the daring, the excitement, out of things.
At the same time, playing ping-pong in Japan
reminds me why choirs regularly enjoy more fun
than soloists.
In a choir, your only job is to play your small part perfectly,
to hit your notes with feeling,
and by so doing, to help to create a beautiful harmony
that's much greater than the sum of its parts.
Yes, every choir does need a conductor,
but I think a choir releases you from a child's simple sense of either-ors.
You come to see that the opposite of winning isn't losing --
it's failing to see the larger picture.
As my life goes on,
I'm really startled to see that no event
can properly be assessed for years after it has unfolded.
I once lost everything I owned in the world,
every last thing, in a wildfire.
But in time, I came to see that it was that seeming loss
that allowed me to live on the earth more gently,
to write without notes,
and actually, to move to Japan
and the inner health club known as the ping-pong table.
Conversely, I once stumbled into the perfect job,
and I came to see that seeming happiness
can stand in the way of true joy
even more than misery does.
Playing doubles in Japan really relieves me of all my anxiety,
and at the end of an evening,
I notice everybody is filing out in a more or less equal state of delight.
I'm reminded every night
that not getting ahead isn't the same thing as falling behind
any more than not being lively is the same thing as being dead.
And I've come to understand why it is
that Chinese universities are said to offer degrees in ping-pong,
and why researchers have found that ping-pong
can actually help a little with mild mental disorders
and even autism.
But as I watch the 2020 Olympics in Tokyo,
I'm going to be keenly aware
that it won't be possible to tell who's won or who's lost
for a very long time.
You remember that point I mentioned
that was said to last for two hours and 12 minutes?
Well, one of the players from that game ended up, six years later,
in the concentration camps of Auschwitz and Dachau.
But he walked out alive.
Why?
Simply because a guard in the gas chamber
recognized him from his ping-pong playing days.
Had he been the winner of that epic match?
It hardly mattered.
As you recall, many people had filed out before even the first point was concluded.
The only thing that saved him
was the fact that he took part.
The best way to win any game,
Japan tells me every other night,
is never, never to think about the score.
Thank you.
(Applause)